si el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin ha
firmado esta mañana el decreto de
anexión de los cuatro territorios que el
ejército ruso tiene ocupados
parcialmente en Ucrania la República
Popular de lugones la República popular
dedo y también las nuevas conquistas
rusas en el sur gerson y saporilla es el
último o el penúltimo paso que quedaba a
la legislativo y a la maquinaria legal
rusa porque estaría pendiente la
inclusión de estos cuatro territorios en
la Constitución rusa puesto que uno de
sus artículos hace un repaso de los
sujetos federales que forman parte Rusia
va a pasar a tener 8,8 millones de
habitantes más un 6% extra de población
Pero sigue con unas fronteras no muy
definidas en el oeste sobre todo en la
región de gerson donde las tropas
ucranianas siguen avanzando ahora mismo
en Rusia todo el mundo muy pendiente de
Qué día se va a dirigir Vladimir Putin
al país porque se temen nuevas medidas
como por por ejemplo un cierre de
fronteras para Los Balones en edad de
combatir O tal vez ley Marcial